so you have been an incredible mixture
of of different expertises which is
really unique in a way and so now this
[ __ ] is to discuss what is missing in
current theories computational theories
of the brain of course I know that maybe
30% of you you have a finished theory in
your head of how things work but so
let's so what I would say so we don't
want mini talks here about it but on the
other hand we want to pick the brains
and get the ideas out right but some
Pete that in mind so just stay in the
flow of the discussion and and I would
say as a general way of structuring this
maybe there is kind of different aspects
to it source to a model of the
computational model of the brain and of
course it's always neat to have but of
course one can ask what are the goals
right so what kind of brains do we want
to model but then also you know what are
the ingredients or also on a mono motive
side what are actually the computations
so we have heard about reinforcement
learning apparently which is very high
up that this is something but is this
you know control theories the brain of
control or is we have thought about
working memory so we have certainly
heels started to forward out certain
principles but is there something
lacking and of course I know there's
more talks to come but so I mean so
there's all kind of different things
that it would be great to collect here
and so maybe to just get started is you
know what do you think what what was
most what was was really missing from
the discussion so far and yeah so so
just yeah it seems that the one
experiment
we were talking about is what all of us
can do right now if you look out the
window you can see leaves on the trees
you could probably get an estimate of
how accurate leads you can represent the
visual world and for me I'd call it Tara
boxes and it's changing quickly and yet
I know the input driving my Tara box of
simulation this minute is at best a
megabyte per second maybe only 10
kilobytes if you believe in rate codes
so somehow my brain is about a million
fold amplification to understand all of
this how do we do 3d so well in our
heads and how of all teachers done it so
well for millions of years
okay I mean the one he'll but once you
stop then I start so what I found a
little bit lacking out sizing you know
reinforcement rolling clearly a very
important principle and I think there
are other intrinsic drives of actually
exploration and behavior that actually
are not so call described by a situation
where you rely on quite immediate
reports and so I was missing also kind
of model driven curiosity as actually a
drive so think of a little kid in a well
fed in a row with a lot of times there's
a beautiful kind of time compressed
version on YouTube this this child
engages with every toy in the room in
the course of two outs there is no food
no directory both involve tea and so
what what what is the drive so I would
be very interested in you know kind of
model-based internal drives that are not
directly related to an external world I
think this is a principle that we also
need to understand better to have self
loathing and learning and love and
lifelong learning systems I think has
written some papers well as many I have
also written page I mean there's many
people who have written tables about
this and it's oh it's actually it's kind
of an old world world from statistics
which is kind of optimal experimental
designs so a lot of these of these of
these models these more normative models
of how actually exploration can happen
by an agent in an unsupervised fashion
they are based on optimal experimental
design the 50s is around and has then we
taken up by Schmidt who book
[Music]
okay so I work on public programming
describing posting models and performing
Bayesian inference in them and so
something that I that I'm you know that
I'm really interested in when I come to
a workshop like this is uh you know
writing computer science we have these
really powerful tools you know for
translating things at one level of
abstraction to a lower one right service
barriers so you know I'm always I'm
always wondering whether there are you
know what's what kinds of you know
theories of neuroscience of how the
brain works
you know what properties would a theory
have that would allow us to build you
know these these barriers of abstraction
these levels of automation on top right
now could I compile out from there or
lassoo program right I promise to
program to to a you know a neural
representation you know something like
language of describing brain
computational learning which and then
look at the publicity programs which is
a well produce T programs are being you
know cognitive scientist liked I'd like
to you know are interested in these
normative Bayesian models of cognition
and so I guess you know what kinds of
computational models of the brain you
know admit you know automated
translation from from higher levels of
abstraction like electron publicity
programs to
so actually you saw someone in your
field
yeah they look like so there's there's
some we're counting fun you know like
representing Kabbalistic models with no
stochastic digital circuits that look
sort of like I think it's it's very
detached certainly a careful about the
brain
I think because of this network that I
could even come I'm kind of not even
genetically coded or transfer knowledge
no it takes the form of public programs
you know such a bunch of burning right
and so this I think it's really good now
program and every signal exactly so I
think learning or different sometimes
nothing we will need pretty much all of
them or variants of all of them and then
integration becomes a big issue I don't
think that we machine the does into
gradient descent overall some modules
that and that relates to your question
curiosity learning do something
reasonable I realized once more us
learning to somehow write history
modular and this substructures have to
work on themselves without really deep
some of the detail what to do so that
poses a unsupervised learning principles
and work to integrate everything another
thing that I think was like completely
is something more abstract reasoning or
so
I mean if you read eco sort of to the
symbolic representation that we are
obviously able to do but I think they
don't have the language at all - I mean
there's some attempts but it's very
limited in terms of silicon to get from
the world sort of the stimulus the
perception to abstract symbolic
oxidation and then do something like
reason I think exactly is this well the
first point that that you make that you
know else different functionally
specialized many in the in the brain and
they can under certain circumstances
communicate with each other and form a
functional network people call a
functional network and and into a
certain task this is it's very hard to
grasp in a model so most of the model
are models that we have are kind of
looking at a local area where the
neurons are doing for very good reasons
because if you ask what is you know for
this ten different regions what are ten
different regions in the cortex doing
together there's tons of unknown
parameters and so it becomes unwieldy
but I think this multi scale aspect of
brain activity and brain organization
would be a very important somehow to
connect to the computational theories
because this is also where there's a lot
of data
of modeling learning or any type
unsupervised supervised very fast Maneri
but he could try to relate it to the
data and i particularly go to synapse
facility I think the link is typically
rather weak then I think we got used to
kind of a certain learning models or
learning rules which are just accepted
by the community but I think they're not
accepted by the physiology community
necessary or at least their questionable
acting which makes it that even more
difficult now to put several such models
together each of them is kind of
questionable and focus on what I'm
missing is the just everything related
the consolidation is just I kind of know
very known Samantha Kristen was so then
right but it can do something very
powerful that I'm missing there you know
any ten to the roots which you can try
out yes so obviously one thing we're
interested in is whether there are
mechanisms in the frame that compose
what do people think about that and come
up with little two-way examples but
where where are there separate
mechanisms that have circuits that
combine to produce an effect that builds
on
where's that just hopeless maybe there's
just too much well I think you know the
data is coming in those connectomics
data so we are starting to get I mean
for a long time people did not really
know much about the connectivities which
spend father distances in cortex because
it's just very hard to try trace these
fibers but there is of course better and
paid off better data coming so I think
it I mean the experimental neuroscience
site else now also an enormous need in
actually good computational concepts
that make predictions and can be tested
I think this is really something to keep
in mind that now actually we are getting
to a realm
you know National Institute of Health
they are putting out programs in our
looking for theory framework because
they are they are drowning in data so
the last five years the first five years
of the brain initiative was very much
focused on gathering data getting
getting better data of neural activity
of connectivity and so on and now it
they want to transition to understanding
the data and so I think there is a very
important Eve now for computational
theories that make testable predictions
that make predictions that can be linked
to this this data probably you're
thinking kind of the whole brain imaging
or almost all levels I mean there's
calcium imaging is scaling up to ten
thousands and probably soon hundred
thousands of neurons so we have
in terms of sites in terms of really
recording single neuron activity not
quieter than the second millisecond
resolution is calcium imaging it's a
little bit low pass filter but not much
so that's one but then there's massive
connectomics of efforts so really of
reconstruct the idea and not only on the
PM levels on the on the on the
resolution level where we see synaptic
contacts so all this data is now
becoming available and it's all supposed
to be shared and investigated and now we
need concepts and frameworks to actually
make sense of it and this is now
realized and so it's an enormous
opportunity but it poses a it's really
in the goal of the theory then has to be
okay
what testable predictions can be made
that somehow connected these data or
also you know how can be info maggin
with all the new techniques that are now
available to to monitor brain activity
to mesh on connectivity and structure in
the brain what is the next killer
experiment what is the next experiment
that we could inform that we could help
to design so that we get an answer that
we can then use to test our theories
so I think that one concrete instance of
this problem will maybe a best tomorrow
by Jason McLean I'm talking about now
this population events assemblies and
SMD sequences and I think that may kind
of notations try to now kind of create a
computation scary how do you compute the
descent base then which is something
different than computing the neurons
because the seventies are someone know
kind of loose snow kind of collisions of
neurons then and so in just I think that
they're in the way of using traditional
concept like the concept that the signal
neuron is encoding something or that
correlation between neurons is calling
something these are kind of larger know
distributed assemblies of neurons which
probably communicate with assemblies and
other brain areas yard and so there's
obviously a problem that now how what is
the right modeling never conceptually
will mess with you know you an assembly
there's no like a binary variable is or
no off them but then you're missing this
kind of loose aspect that on each trial
assembly within no engagements not a
different set up the reason then you
could do this on a low level now you're
losing though the structure because
everything becomes so complicated
yeah I mean the set the Sanderson the
Sentry concept is a very interesting one
very old basically started in a way with
with William chains already entirely
without data but then with of course
with Donald hat intend with Carl Ashley
and it's still around India still
there's now data also that some foreign
some against this assembly concept so
some some of the data like didna planes
stayed at NIH he sees more these 1 over
F distributions it doesn't seem to be a
certain fixed sets of assemblies of
cells that always go on together with
each other but it seems more
like a scale-free phenomenon but so
there's actually interesting statistical
data also well one can now start so for
a long time the cell assembly hypothesis
was considered a experimentally
untestable prediction if the sim please
are small and sparse because one
couldn't recall from enough neurons but
this is now also changing so we can now
really spell out what you know with the
cell is simply a theory would predict
them one can look into data
what isn't in the right previous in some
sense to describe to break anyone by
either designers
but then then this thing that actually
exists and then I guess it's maybe it's
some sense but can we understand the
branding brain until we are able to
connect
so whatever series where you do with
with the Big C with the consciousness
right I mean this is fundamentally what
what we are I think pointless games and
even have a serial brain without making
this connection somehow quantity right
and I have no idea which we even do try
to start
I think there's really also extra
mentally we don't have good access to
what consciousness disagree then I think
we look simply at different authors no
published papers about consciousness you
find not that most of them have actually
one definition but everyone has somewhat
different and a precise definition but
this is probably not what Ilya has in
mind and so I think as ever I hesitate
to write it down because I think
partially the problem or our
consciousness that everybody has a
different idea in mind I was in day snow
without making progress no you first you
have to make a list of what aspects of
consciousness to really address at the
moment and right and then by one by one
I think one can yeah one thing that I
haven't heard very much here and that is
just the tremendous capacity or range
the story informations memory long-term
memory me and how fast it can form and
how permanent it can be and we probably
will not find answers to that kind of
question simply by looking at simple
simple neurons I think we need to create
develop a theory of computation that is
rich enough to capture in a physical
system the the behavior that that that
all of us depend on I amuse Eason can
recall hundreds of thousands of Tunes by
just hearing a little bit of it and some
of us many of us wheat from one language
to another but we never lose our accent
so some things get established early on
and then they stay with us and other
things are very flexible and we can you
know things like that we can express the
same thing in two different languages
and it doesn't I mean the next day we
didn't don't even know remember in what
language we heard it so something like
that a physical system is able to do
because our brains do it and we really
don't have a good theory for that but
but we need to look at I mean
psychologists know a lot of interesting
things that we could look at silencing
memory models because the literature is
full of memory models for studying with
health food network so we would address
but particularly deficiencies of
existing models then can we know well
like hopfield net how much can you store
in a hopfield net learner life work life
where for the series station fits with a
high capacity right that's linear and
you have billions of neurons so why
isn't this enough so I think this is not
before miss amber pence is getting at is
this the immense capacity but you're
making a theoretical argument I mean
that's great but I mean let's we
implement this in practice and they won
when one one experiment we can look at
is the experience of standing in the
1970s he measured the capacity for
picture memory and it's really
astounding experiments where they just
showed human subjects pictures as she's
so like one picture you know a second or
two and they're just like photographs of
entire scene and what he found is the
capacity for your memory there's the
order of 10,000 pictures meaning I can
show you study list of 10,000 pictures
and then come along later with a test
picture and ask you was that in the
study list or not they're wave about to
play about chance and it takes
week to do the experiment have a subject
you know sit down and watch all these
pictures how do you how do you build a
neural network that does that in a
holistic and robust way and I think
that's kind of just an explanatory gap
there I mean we still gonna bet make
these maybe theoretical scaling
arguments but actually implementing that
in practice and making it work and
making a proboscis something the
organization of that memory very
important in two ways physical
organization and then organizational
information in terms of ability to
access it so you have you have both it
both for the physical plant and then you
have an Oliver rhythms that gets used
that physical plants so that you can you
can access the memory with very fast
with with they cues and actually cues
from amount of defense senses for
example there's an old result
recognition memory as a capacity that's
order and swear so it's not that it's in
principle mana for example I think human
memory actually if there's no strong
evidence and it's extremely high
capacity right
for example the the white house right if
you know your our lives of interment
like inhabitants of that house how many
columns
Poliquin both sides I think what she's
getting at is the incredible in
Berryessa
every stuff that we know that we can get
memories through different modalities
and store that we can unify the
precision system and so on and so forth
and that we forget I mean that's
irrelevant to us and preferences for
what's relevant to us how we determine
relevance of the time to storage memory
serves a purpose a very human purpose
and how is it the circus combined
purpose with memory storage so you're
arguing for no kind of fitting into
something that you want to have no
selectivity for important aspects of
there's another thing that's happening
and given technological advances I think
a lot of theorists are having this
experimentalists are coming to us and
asking us know now I can do anything I
can record four thousand neurons I can
move into all optical read and write I
can play in any activity you wanted to
be one or orbitofrontal cortex I can
record response of 4,000 cells there
what should I do
right the fact that we as theorists
can't often design killer experiments to
tell them exactly what to write it into
the brain suggests about Phebe's our art
are not negotiating the correct
trade-off between sort of abstract power
and precision of the level of biophysics
right like I see lots of really
interesting questions about roseburg for
deeper abstract theories some questions
about like biophysics but how do we
match the two to injustice to be
credible technology developments
happened now how do we turn that
technology development
to advance I think that's one of the
main challenges that we possibly face
yeah protected from ominous proposals
about other deficiency of existing
member models I'm not sure hope your has
addressed it I think the one thing we
are going to use to in the Hope Food
Network but you store there s binary
patterns by your clinician role to be
one or zero memorize and so this I'm not
even sure how brain could do this right
you see something how do i clamp on
neurons know in my mind deeper and
higher brain areas right so therefore
now there's something there hidden the
runs in the brain right these are not
claimed by the external encode that you
memorize and i'm missing really now kind
of interesting models from memory which
have hidden neurons and right and the
use of this hidden neurons recruit them
for certain memories and connect them
for certain memories right and i think
thats related to the formation of
abstractions right because that's what
was hidden neurons should be doing is
forming a stratum at across situations
they constitute the basis for a memory
in a modality and in fashion
a part that we're using many of the
series which do not look at the
development how do you build the robust
robust behavior rather than train and an
already existing structure right this is
a very different potentially very
different questions and similar saying
maybe is I don't think we have enough
data at the moment to understand for
example your I can walk right you become
brains how much variability is served
between the let's say motor behavior is
that you and I exhibit versus how much
variability deserved it with the brain
structures responsible is there more one
or under how do we develop this robust
behaviour and do it actually robust
development for that one or not right
[Music]
they can focus beyond about three inches
Portage's right and then you can only
focus in DDT by age nine or eight or
something like that if I get the real
applet in the words do not get trained
on images with all sorts of details of
existence out it's assuming just because
they don't see the leaves and faraway
trees right unlike the when betrayed and
network right a big network is there
something that has some principles of
how one builds repeat more robustly
performing robustly
robustly acting since which which are
not just instantaneous training but but
building together who's training another
IP and formulating that's right but I
think we should probably not try not to
abide in the discussion above everything
I don't know about the brain but really
what is missing in computation series
about the brain right and so this would
be then maybe be the crash you know kind
of how to have a theory of robust kind
of developed development I don't sure
what it means development is something
huge right
how'd you build up this hierarchical
structure where there's something that
is fairly because I think you can pick
many things right immediately you know
get into the lick of data and so how can
you do Siri in spite of this make up a
reverse side to this so you cannot
assume that everything is learned I mean
every person has visual cortex and exact
same place right so it's not it doesn't
just randomly wire up so that we can see
or even even more I mean if we if weeks
if we if we look at non-human animals a
fly gets out the closes gate gets out of
the fuel pilot can fly almost right away
and ungulate or a lot of precocious
animals in general they can run faster
than we do and a few hours after they're
born they don't learn why doesn't learn
to see it's it's boring seeing the
actual what we think as learning models
there's actually an infrastructure laid
in the axonal guidance in all the
developing in all the development
structures which is certainly I mean our
genetic code doesn't code for strengths
of specific synapses but it codes for
the way though the brain wires up it's
for the rules in anything is the
difference now driven by the private
magic have slightly different brains or
is more different brains whether this is
a little bit of a comment a kind of meta
comment about the discussion and
thinking about how a new field of
science emerges and so famously Thomas
Kuhn talked about the emergence of
paradigms and those and what I find a
mystery of science and so the listening
to the discussion is interesting too I
think maybe one thing that's missing is
thinking about what are and that's what
this process is you know what the
paradigmatic problem is who famously
said that fields emerge by solving
paradigmatic problems that then attract
researchers to that problem when I hear
this discussion there are multiple
different paradigmatic problems and
though what is a very dramatic problem
for professor Ganguly and professor
Deneb is it quite different from what is
the paradigmatic problem from someone in
neuroscience so my one suggestion would
be to think about a what is the very
dramatic problem for April particular
group of people and what their training
is that makes them see that as a big
paradigmatic problems because Kuhn also
of course said that the paradigm is an
imagined endpoint of what the science
would be and those endpoints which
professor Ganguly is describing at once
a certain theoretical level of
abstraction is is that's a standard that
you are bringing to this discussion as
part of your lab so we and so in that
respect I would say one big distinction
is those people who think of themselves
as
the leaders of the brain and modelers
consumers versus those who are thinking
this is computing and they see there's
kind of like two different there's a
little bit of tension in kind of two
different end points for about
computation series for the brain this is
nothing - I'm a sexy in my dark hours
ask myself to what extent can actually
convince myself that what we're doing
this science then as opposed to really
systematic speculation then certain
characteristic features for science for
example that they will take experimental
data really serious and I don't see this
relation in my community so I think this
is a bit loosely inspired by
experimental data but I think it's not I
think driven by extramental in the same
way reading of physics is driven by data
from experimental physics them and I
think it's both ways I mean society is
also that the experimenters often do not
really pay attention to what theories
are that they come up with their own
theories for the better or the goals as
I feel there's an entire field I see
this now as a chance that dis dis very
these very passionate data are now
coming in in the experimental labs this
is a chance
so maybe come up with a common paradigm
which is really something that actually
unites theory and experimental field
sometimes in if you look in theoretical
neuroscience
little plans of people who are here to
sell ideas of models and kind of defend
them but we really need is to get to the
cycle of experimentation and testing
predictions of the theory and then
improving the theory and so on
I mean that could maybe be such a common
paradigm so I don't think this can just
come from us as as all the models and
theorists and I think also there is
actually not I mean no one is just one
so superbe I think it's always you
always want to understand us always even
in the most complicated simulation as
abstraction I think what's interesting
is just to to be conscious about and
think about what are the standards of
the different sub groups making up this
and what would the standards be in the
future so tonight I just in this
discussion I've heard testing hypothesis
robustness hierarchical structure a
higher theoretical level of
understanding and its kind of standards
which are not conflicting but they're
different people bring those as their
requirements for valid knowledge today
if say resume I'm coming so on and
somebody knows lipid know consumer from
kind of know with medics machine
learning I'm always concerned simply
about this meta aspect of overfitting
then we build models which have many
more parameters typically right and if
you succeed with this modeling I'm not
sure what it tells us then because
assuming then the next day the
experimental data that there won't the
model are kind of very withdrawn then it
turns out no just opposite is true you
go back to our model and we I'm
certainly but also be able to reproduce
so this kind of completely different
extra mental
so I'm not quite sure where that we
really provide really useful
understanding of extra mental data by
modeling this extra mental data in the
way no that can be described as
overfitting from the best practice or
statistics of machine learning on the
positive side
what are becoming what are the
computational theories that are not
missing I just want to know what what do
you guys agree on this name one or two
things that everybody says yes this is
no really I mean what I think that would
be a good I mean if we can't answer that
question is something wrong the other
thing that we had a civil discussion
Geneva and then the researcher who made
such gave a few examples know for such
things we really know also we can so as
proof that new science has made progress
and one of this was mentioned know
really know that we have know this we
reinforce fanatics Ewing that behave
this global robot signals and know then
we have a principal understanding out
know reinforcement learning machine
learning and for me for example this is
something which is not so clear if we if
we look at the data was much like a lot
of itten from Princeton or they really
question quite a bit this global robot
signal for example in the brain right
now it's kind of different kind of
dopamine kind of no outputs are sent to
different brain areas and also it's now
that they don't just signal about so
even though
those examples which seemed to be no
prime candidates for such theory
everybody agrees on I think that a
little bit kind of no becoming less firm
ground and in the face of new emerging
extramental data then so maybe we can
best agree on those things where we have
few extra metadata to mention them I
think probably this agreement is also
that we all working on different
problems and within the problem that I
think there's some agreement about
things maybe that suck up to this
disease so I think party petitioning and
you I think you also make a comment why
should we just all focus on one problem
and solve that right and I feel very
good that we split over different topics
but that also makes the typical and
virtually impossible to agree on one
thing very difficult work on different
things
avoid this
you should have some clarity in terms of
the brain actually what percentage of
the cake
I mean the right is done because in
principle I think it's over the middle
of perspective or so our semantics
really what people call supervised
unsupervised learning about sugar that I
don't see the scientific yes so um I
come from machine learning so I really
know very little but very little about
neuroscience and among the many things
that are really wrong with machine
learning there's one thing that seems to
have worked which is rallying a
community behind benchmarks as horrible
as many aspects of this up but maybe
connecting this to a couple of things
that came up in the last couple of
questions might be interesting one of
them is what can everyone agree on what
theories can people agree on well maybe
there's also a list of tasks or
canonical types of experiments or
aspirational type of if you wish
performance on some things that one
could connect and that also addresses
some of the first things that were
addressed for instance model based
learning model driven learning
integration of their most learning
modules and so on so is there a list of
if you wish tasks that you know a
collection of theorists could define
that everyone agrees on these things
should work and then questions like the
last one what part of the cake is this
what part of the cake is that become a
question of empirical inference right we
can actually test this I mean you can't
well actually I think neuroscience is
discussing a lot about Ben Jackson there
are efforts now like this International
Neuroscience Institute well actually you
know 15 laps or all of the same
decision-making experiment in a so there
are these things but of course you know
science doesn't want to give up the
diversity because it's not clear you
know maybe it's for example the progress
that we have been made making planning
some of the compositor owns and stuff
like that that was amazing it's there's
amazing insights in actually in very
smaller brains but then you could say
okay with us this help us to spend
context in and that's thoughtful now I
think it's mean definitely we should
work towards bench biases also the other
tension here is you want to study that
naturalistic and communicative behavior
from the more neurons you recall then
actually sujes a very nice kind of
difference you also want to study more
and more naturalistic more and more
complicated behaviors but for that
reason you know science hesitates to say
okay everyone studies now this behavior
this behavior because we might zoom in
too early on to something that for
example envision people for four decades
have just stopped is that it means that
it is very artificial stimuli like
sideways frames and things like that
Ellucian that actually if you built the
best models that predict the new firing
in viewing these these artificial
stimulant helped you to predict what
actually the neurons are doing if the
animal views is seen that it actually
encounters in its natural life and that
will see just to clarify because maybe
you can stay for moments to like this
person so you are giving a position
about this question about benchmarks for
computation series I think it's a very
nice address if you should possibly try
to decide when it's impossible or
useless or know they exist candidates
for this then and I think this may also
be addressed this several overfitting
problem because in the computer science
innocence I mentioned this now when you
have an algorithm you don't just know
verify that it works for five different
inputs right should work in principle
for all this exponentially many
different encoding so this is the
typical benchmark test for verifying I
would the performance of an algorithm
right it's not quite clear now what this
would be then well I think it's for
example sharing data that's a very
important thing if someone does an
experiment then writes conclusions in
the paper
share the day now let other people
that's kind of a concept of it was a
little bit of the finer point to what I
was saying obviously people share data
everyone has their own experiment which
single model is you know tested for a
particular phenomenon it is testing but
there's a bigger point that is already
on that board and that is one what can
we all agree on so maybe there's a
collection of tasks that could be
outlined as a map of what an integrated
model of many of these things together
has to be able to do to it already talks
about model-based learning this already
already a point about integrating of
different integration of different
modules so what I'm arguing for or
questioning about sort of is not how
would we evaluate each single model and
how are people creative about testing
each different type of if you wish
phenomenon but bringing some of these
aspects together and testing them as at
home can we think about what are the
tasks as a whole that we say you know a
computational model of the brain should
be able to address
I think that yeah we should maybe
collect my opinions to this important
point I think money experience no just
ahead no form any discussion at this
point of this type and they're often
kept arrive at some point at the
challenge for benchmark tasks and then
they say okay let's go collect some
benchmark cos it never happens and next
year we'll be coming back little self on
so there is apparently a reason why we
never managed to agree on benchmark pass
right so which could be not really be
rooted in the nature of our discipline
our society simply a hobby back then I
think maybe should address benchmark is
the criteria by which you very clear in
the data also also effective function I
think that's something that is much less
clear than the task itself and I
actually someone here I tell you that
this is actually good that we don't
decide on one way to evaluate it because
I think speaking of benchmarks so
Jessica comes in very concrete in mind
the imagenet classification was a
benchmark for a while but now it's the
bounding boxes and figuring out where
things are in the picture is there any
chance of or something like that exists
you know
and the same classification understand
how the position of different signatures
sort of passing remember that there are
kids no specification tasks like
viciousness you know whether they can be
used you know know in order to probe
given us the only story that theorists
are going back to what's a theory of the
brain and we can make predictions and
that's a theory now it's become a theory
came out of its totally benchmark
treatment forget about neurons but just
do it the best way you can
given these computing resources or or
whatever you can get your hands up no
tell us how many you know how many
computers GPUs you actually use it over
time but like figure out this problem
that most of the problems that
neuroscientists look at are actually not
that hard anymore we used to be able to
say gosh human brain you can balance
better it can you understand spoken
language and like we're not getting down
you know at a rapid pace now but we're
doing it in a different way although now
we're saying it is the same way but you
can't use bench performance benchmarks
of tasks so much at and apply to those
theories and movies
be satisfying a sort of a reductionist
level that's that's it's hard to sort of
quantify I'm not sure I mean how would
you have a theory they never this is a
better theory than this is but but just
to bring this up boxes loops us right
but if you don't have data you can test
your theory in any way having common
data sets and consolidate people around
programs certainly in tension with
making you know progress on single
things but the only thing that I was
sort of advocating after looking at what
theories can we agree on this can we
agree upon this set of tasks and data
set which may be jointly theory should
be consistent so instead of optimizing
for a single thing
first just define tasks but maybe we
think that what just one point to follow
the so this gentleman is pointing out
the benchmark worked really well for
these nets but as as as you're pointing
out it can also be constraining and as I
understand that the LST function that
was there in kind of deeper and
professor Moss's work which now does
equally well had to come from the
outside so it was not the product of
benchmark its introducing a totally
different kind of quite different
approach to to solve the same problem
but it was not benchmarking neither of
those two innovations since it was a
signal in some sense we benefited from
simply standard tests knowing artificial
neural networks right now how do you
test the Atlas TM network but are they
good at one if you wouldn't have this
then I think it would be more difficult
to simply know characterize that this
adapting the moon spec bring progress
through this networks right so there was
a certain kind of really skeleton or
framework right of test know and then
comparison models I think this head I
think that you can use I think more of
machine learning models end result
simply as a comparison kind of framework
for models then if I may change the
subject
so you know perhaps we can learn a lot
from other theories from other
disciplines that have been very
successful and I'm thinking about you
know theory of computation curing and
then get there some publicity I'm
thinking about general theory of the DVD
I'm thinking about the theory of
evolution so if you look at all of these
theories what do they have in common
I mean clearly they were very successful
right well one thing is that they were
not trying to explain every observation
every data that has been collected in
that field and occurring was not trying
to you know say how do you design a
computer in hardware so I think an
interesting thing about these theories
is that they were setting like a new
agenda they were basically perhaps
motivated by some of the relations from
experiments data but they were really
like providing a new framework a
completely different agenda on how to
approach understanding say gravity or
understanding you know evolution and and
of course you can find exceptions that
perhaps those curls don't explain very
well but that's not the point right here
in neuroscience when I find out is that
we're very easily basically kill
theories because oh look you know this
doesn't really agree with this
observation but they also had many of
them that's the so of course we would
like to compare theories and eventually
kill so
the point is there is no average Mouse
right there is no average human here
proposals we are building model at
average Mouse and I don't know the
average for you know the triple answer
sentencing you do this most organisms
also learning system typically now if
you give the model you instance a the
same learning Elizabeth different
English translations you will get
somewhat different results and is this a
typical effect of learning proven
systems no that is not a canonical
solution but several solutions that work
I agree with this but on the other hand
one we think is programmable they which
the average learning curve right we
didn't try to Sara Lee to ins for
example learning German cities illusion
of possibility crops that would come out
from experiments versus from your
learning one and I think that this
potentially trying to think about the
average behavior with individual
trajectories you know how individual
bird wants to sing will actually tell
about how the bird brain there's didn't
work from a martyr's lab from about
twenty years ago that you just shows
that averaging fail spectacularly that
you have regions of correct function in
the parameter space but if you take the
average over individual parameters you
end up in the region which to response
to something absurd so yes absolutely
yeah that that's that's an extremely
valid point but I'm trying to write a
few words because in some sense I think
it's nice but also it's something know
how to reconcile it with the goal of
theory right theory I want to have a
general invariant rules and right now so
now this is the theory of individuality
which is not sure what is this area for
this of course then the search is for
principles that actually are evolved to
produce this way of knowing bearing
principles which explain many different
individual kind of solutions to
computation okay we are nearing the or
is
just make a small comment about the
benchmark question do I notice that
people use visual demotion to make
claims about whether their theory of
vision okay
and thank you everyone see during the
like what is I think we have four tuned
for another workshop
[Applause]